the end of our offices as we know it  Danny your desk is so empty nothing's  labels but I seen ours ever again except  this show stoppa your desk looks a  little empty yes I probably's goddamn  oktoberfest glasses like you're keeping  all of your glass oh my god you gonna  take this carrot we bought from okay  everyone get out of carrots go through  your mileage out of them those are good  carrot diffic truck him up all these  games you imagine me actually game for a  laptop specific were these overall  minute God ranka someone's office you  can't just walk into my home I didn't  know you were promoted congratulation  it's in drinkin beers loss of 98% L what  a pieces  you  I